le vent de nord dick impact a commencé à
souffler hier soir au cargö ça continue
au parc des expos jusqu'à samedi
on vous en parle qu'est ce que vous
allez bien pouvoir écouter et voir ici
jusqu'à samedi on vous dit tout
alors je regarde la programmation ça a
commencé hier soir on a parlé mais il ya
cinquante deux artistes 52,6 ont tout ce
qui se passe tandis que d'hier soir mais
ça coûte cher ça oui mais ça fait la
demande aussi et puis c'est plaisant
d'avoir multiplié ses formats festival
l'idée c'est aussi de voir un maximum de
choses dans différents endroits de ce
soir dans des petits endroits à vendredi
samedi au parc des expositions est ce
que la musique électronique a beaucoup
évolué on voit des platines on voit des
choses ici devant nous est-ce que ça a
beaucoup évolué techniquement
aujourd'hui la musique électronique
c'est vraiment introduit dans toutes les
musiques c'est ça qui est important à
retenir je pense
c'est l'avant garde toujours c'est
toujours l'avant-garde c'est là où l'on
teste un peu je pense on sait
que j'attends c'est un laboratoire c'est
un laboratoire c'est parti il ya très
longtemps que ce qu'on appelait une
musique concrète le tester le sont
testés certain effet certains types de
machines pour amener de nouveaux sons
et aujourd'hui c'est encore le cas avec
les nouvelles possibilités sur des
ordinateurs qui évolue qui sont plus en
plus puissants et la puissance à rennes
aussi des nouvelles possibilités donc le
way rente est toujours de jour en jour
courant et on va bien s'éclater ici
alors ce soir vous avez compris c'est
plutôt un appartement palais réservé
mais par contre vendredi et samedi au
parc des expositions alors on attend
beaucoup de monde et vous pouvez venir
encore parce qu'il ya des places
il reste des places effectivement mais
vous attend mais faut pas tuer les
cochons nordik impakt jusqu'à samedi
soir à cordes du profane qui souligne
maintenant d'une chapelle à londres
voici de l'art contemporain dans la peau
est l'ocb à tessy-sur-vire dans l'usiné
utopik caroline le méhauté et lawrence
nycholat sont deux plasticiennes elles
sont en résidence ici depuis le 30 août
elle expose à partir de demain vendredi
venez voir on va habiter le temps
oh
je le dise pose tout du long je parcours
vélo en le tâche temps avec l entrée du
sud après ce qui m'intéresse vraiment
s'est montré comment finalement un
élément additionner par accumulation va
devenir un tout qui va tenir de lui-même
ici on a de la tourbe qui vient de
baupte donc c'est la tour de la région
notre quart d'heure d'ici et je
travaille et je travaille beaucoup avec
la terre comme matière première comme
élément sur lequel nous marchons tous
les jours c'est notre socle et le fait
de relever le plan est de le mettre face
à nice c'est une manière de dire et
alors qu'est ce que tu fais avec sa
maman
c'est un peu des métaphores des êtres
jeu je pose qui évoquerait notre notre
passage sur sur terre le fait qu'on soit
des êtres assez vulnérable qui subissons
aussi les aléas du temps l'exposition
habiter le temps c'est à l'usiné utopik
de tessy-sur-vire jusqu'au 4 décembre
en termine avec deux concerts à vous
annoncer pour demain soir ce carré anne
roth
les anciens de morcheeba demain soir au
big band café à hérouville
olivier nouvelle sera notre invité
demain soir dans leur bouche il est en
concert au château de creully avec deux
autres dates ce week-end on vous dit
tout demain soir c'est bien sûr dans le
cadre de jazz dans les prés
demain il